this is an Army enlistment Center in
Siberia
a young man opens fire reportedly upset
that his best friend had been called up
to fight
is more than 6 000 kilometers from
Ukraine but the war is no longer distant
here
is much closer to the fighting just
across the border from Ukraine
the emotion here sadness fear and
defiance
thank you
everybody is scared the main thing is
for him to come back alive and healthy
I'm positive I will come back alive and
healthy it's going to be okay I'm a
sergeant in the reserve
as the reservists leave for the front
line
[Applause]
[Music]
an admission from the Kremlin that it
has made mistakes implementing the draft
you have Houston
[Applause]
area University
most of those who don't want to fight
haven't protested they've simply left
thousands of cars queuing at the border
with Georgia
frustration breaking out among those
stuck in the 20 kilometer long queue
those who have made it to Georgia's
capital to belisi say they feel safe
here
we like many others fear that against
our will they could draft us to go and
kill peaceful people in Ukraine we are
completely against this war and we call
it for what it is it's not an operation
it's a war which Russia is conducting on
the territory of Ukraine for us like for
others it's scary to die and to kill
others and for what we don't understand
therefore we decided to flee at this
time
just
back in Russia sporadic protests
continue
jakovsk is the capital city of the Saha
Republic
these people choose traditional dance to
demonstrate their opposition to the
draft
24 of them were reportedly later
arrested
a recognition by the Kremlin that
mistakes have been made in the draft may
or may not be enough to calm the
protests but that may be beside the
point if Russia and next is large parts
of eastern Ukraine with the redrawing of
the Frontiers enabling Moscow to use
enemies to defend what will be the
motherland Muhammad Al Jazeera Moscow